Massachusetts senator and possible
presidential hopeful Elizabeth Warren
released results of a DNA test
she says proves she has some Native
American heritage President Trump has
mocked Warren's ancestry claims and
derisively referred to her as Pocahontas
at O'Keefe is in Washington with this
one at good morning good morning John
the campaign style video seeks to
directly address questions about her
Native American heritage it's a
controversy that's dog Warren ever since
she first ran for the Senate six years
ago and the new push is just the latest
sign that she's actively preparing to
run for president in 2020 president
Trump didn't back down from his attacks
on Warren who released a video made with
him in mind the president likes to call
my mom a liar what are the facts say
Warren enlisted a Stanford University
DNA researcher for the test the report
suggests Warren has just a trace of
Native American heritage but she first
publicly identified as such in the late
1980s I've got the controversy has made
Warren an irresistible target for the
president they call her Pocahontas
Pocahontas was up and she was so angry
the biographical video I used my mama's
grit to get through commuter college and
law school comes after Warren said she
would look at running for president
setting her up as an early 2020 opponent
for the present who's already practicing
for a matchup we will say I will give
you a million dollars to your favorite
charity paid for by Trump if you take
the test that it shows you're an idiot
Warren wants the President to make good
on that bet tweeting he should send a
check to charity but mr. Trump imposed
some conditions I'll only do it if I can
test her personally
okay that will not be something I enjoy
doing either Warren criticized the
president for that response at a 28
tweet storm of her own calling the
president a bully who scares easy and we
should note that the Cherokee Nation
criticized Warren's announcement saying
that her use of a DNA test is
inappropriate and quote undermining
tribal interests with her continued
claims of tribal heritage
bianna a lot of people questioning
whether this revelation really did win
her in any points edie thank you